I wanna talk about the history of women using male pseudonyms JK
Rowling and gender fluidity and where the conversation is at today
so I'm Doctor Zoe
I have a PhD in digital feminist activism and I talk a lot about hot
sticky feminist topics
so I've noticed recently that there is growing discourse about how JK
Rowling is using gender fluidity to her own advantage
while denying others the opportunity to do the same
and this is so interesting to me because years and years ago
I brought this up when she started using Robert Galbraith
um to publish under for her crime series
and obviously she's always said that she used JK
so that people would know that her name was Joanne
so that she could kind of benefit from the Assumption that she was a man
but a few years ago people would not into that argument
pro trans people would say well
it's different it's not the same
you can't equate transness with using male pseudonym
JK Rowling has been doing this for years since the start
and I wanna talk about why it's suddenly an accepted argument to use
when a few years ago it wasn't
so the reason is
really that society's understanding of gender expression
has progressed a lot in the last five or 10 years
so this is now exposing JK
Rowling's hypocrisy in a way that it previously wasn't really widespread
understood so firstly
let's look at how the trans rights debate has evolved
so JK
Rowling's position on trans rights has been very fixed in gender essentialism
the idea that your gender is determined by your biology at birth
and is immutable so
it's no longer lost on people that those who prescribe to the idea of gender
like JK Rowling believe the gender is very firmly fixed
should not be
then using gender fluidly in the way that they portray themselves to the world
I think it's also really important to acknowledge at this point
that the use of male pseudonyms by female authors is not at all a new thing
we know about the Bronte sisters that wrote under the bell brothers
we know George Elliott did this
whose name is actually Marianne Evans
and this is very much lauded as a feminist thing
that they had to do to get by in a patriarchy
they would have never gotten published otherwise
if you read the forwards to the Bronty sisters books
defending that they are the bell brothers
it's very funny now that we know that they are the Bronty sisters
but I think it's well understood that this is just resistance against patriarchy
and is very accepted and very acceptable that women in 19th century did this
let's talk about what makes it different when JK
Rowling does it
it's pretty clear she didn't do it to gain entry into the literary world
she was already a huge success um
with Harry Potter obviously
before she came out as Robert Galbraith
so she didn't really need to do it
it's more something that she wanted to do
and I believe that she wanted to continue to operate with the same privileges um
that she had before and actually be able to put her work out there
without the previous judgement of Harry Potter
so it wasn't something that she did for necessity
but rather something that she did um
to extend her privilege um to
to extend the way her books would be received
and I think that these days that comes across very inauthentic to people
people find that to be yeah
not really the vibe so
we have rolling a cisgender woman
being able to fluidly navigate between the genders as she pleases
depending on how she wants her persona to be portrayed
depending on how she wants people to perceive her work and her writing
meanwhile she is spreading trans hate
but the next thing I wanna talk about for a little bit of a tricky thing
it's about the evolution of the way that we understand gender and transness
we used to very much rely on this idea of born in the wrong body um
that you've got a dysphoria that needs to be changed and fixed
and I think that we are progressing beyond just that
as an understanding of transness
this kind of rhetoric also mirrors the gay rights movement that
where we really spoke about gayness for a very long time
as I was born this way and it is in my biology somehow that I am gay
and that was a really necessary
I guess way
way to talk about it to get conservative buy in um
for the gay rights movement
but I think now sexuality is understood as a lot more fluid on that
and a lot more influenced by our agency and our society
um social conditioning
um what's acceptable
um as well as how you were born
so let's take the concept of political lesbianism
I know this is very controversial and a lot of people don't like the idea of it
people are threatened by the idea that you might be able to choose
that's because we relied on the idea that you can't choose
to show that gay people should have human rights
so this idea was essential to the gay rights movement
because it really neutralized conservative opposition to um
different sexualities people like to understand something as fixed and innate
and struggle with anything else
people feel threatened by the idea that maybe sexuality is a little fluid
sometimes um
and a little flexible and people struggle with understanding gender the same way
but I believe we're undertaking a shift right now
where people are beginning to understand gender as a lot less fixed
lot more fluid and flexible
we are moving beyond the born this way narrative
that is the logical conclusion that I don't think people have been able
to hasn't been making sense to me for a long time
why people haven't been able to see that
but to me that's the logical conclusion
go back to our Queen of fantasy
JK Rowling
now I wanted to use the JK
Rowling example to discuss this
because I think it is a great signifier for where we're at in this conversation
and how it's progressed moving beyond the rigid and the fixed
and the irony of someone who uses fluid gender constructs for personal gain
and personal wealth
while also throwing trans people under the bus is now very obvious to everyone
I think this marks a shift in our consciousness about gender
and how we're understanding it
as expressive as fluid
and we're rejecting the rigidity of the previous conversation
thanks for listening I'm Doctor Zoe and I have written about this on substack
which you can now subscribe to
to support survivors and you can also buy our merch